-Sarah Michelle Gellar!
-You have the best band.
Do you ever, like -- You just have the best band.
Like, I would just -- I would get so distracted.
Like, I want to talk to you, but I also kinda want to listen.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Very, very lucky.
It is so great to see you. You look fantastic.
-Yeah. Subtle. Very subtle. -Thank you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. They're great and everything.
-They are wonderful. -Yeah, they are wonderful.
-I know. It's been a long time. -How have you been?
How is everything doing? How's Freddie doing?
-It's good. I mean, you know, luckily you haven't had drinks
with him recently, so I haven't lost him
to a foreign country for four months at a time.
True story. A long time ago,
Freddie went out with Jimmy and his parents.
-My mom and dad. -And -- Yes.
And, um, a few drinks were had.
And the next thing -- -They loved him so much.
-Oh. Oh, yeah. I think they were --
I mean, we were planning to go to your house for Christmas.
-Yeah. My dad was calling him "son" at one point.
-Absolutely. [ Laughter ]
But, yeah, they got my husband to agree to go to London
for, I don't know, like, three months to do a play.
He woke up the next morning, and he was like, "What did I say I'd do?"
I'm like, "Oh, you're doing a show."
-Yeah. There was some director or someone there.
And they said, "Yeah, I wrote this play. Do you want to do it?"
And he agreed that night that we were out.
-And apparently that's binding, so be careful what you drink.
You might wind up in a new show.
-But, alright. So wait. How long have you guys been married?
-We have been married -- uh, married over 20 years.
-Wow. -I had to think about it.
I had to think about that.
-You guys -- That's the best. You've gotta give him my best.
And how are the kids? How old are the kids?
-They're good. Well, you should know --
Because this is very important that I say this.
My daughter wanted me to remind you
that she is your birthday twin. -She is?
-And she takes -- she takes a lot of pride in it.
But what's funny was my son was also almost your birthday twin.
Because my kids were --
So, my daughter, for her third birthday,
we asked what she wanted, and all she wanted was her brother.
But he wasn't due for three weeks.
But apparently my daughter gets what she wants,
and thankfully, for the 12 hours --
They're the day after, so -- But we almost had two of --
Both my kids would be your birthday twin.
-September 19th. Virgo.
-Yep. So now September 19th and September 20th.
-What is her name again?
-My name? -No. Your daughter's name.
-Oh, I was like...
"We've known each other this long..."
-Who -- Who are you again? -Sar-ah!
-Sarah, yeah, yeah, yeah. -Sar-ah.
-Just wondering -- Yeah. -Charlotte and Rocky.
-Yeah. Charlotte, happy birthday. Rocky, happy birthday.
But hi, Charlotte.
-Sarah. -Oh, my God.
-I really thought you were... -What are you talking about?!
-You meet a -- You meet a lot of people.
I don't know. -I've known you forever!
Oh, my gosh. You're one of the --
By the way, you were one of the best hosts
I've ever worked with on "Saturday Night Live."
-Aww. -I just want to say.
You were phenomenal. -Thank you.
-I loved working with you every single time.
-It was such a dream. And I also --
The day that I knew that, like, I was finally in
and had respect was, we were doing a skit one time
and we just couldn't stop laughing.
And Lorne yelled at me -- just like he yelled at you.
And I was like, "Oh! He thinks I'm one of the cast."
-Yes! -I was like, "Yes, I made it!
Lorne yelled at me!" -You feel my pain. Exactly.
-Then afterwards, I was like, "Oh, I just got yelled at."
But it was, like, one of those moments
where, like, I felt good about it.
-Yeah, I mean, you have those things,
but also we were talking backstage.
We were talking about "Buffy."
And we were saying that I heard that somewhere --
[ Cheers and applause ]
I read somewhere that Dolly Parton
was an uncredited producer. -Yes.
Little-known fact. The legend Dolly Parton was a producer.
And, you know, we never saw her. Like, we'd get Christmas gifts in the beginning
that would have our name, and I would think, "She doesn't know who I am."
And then one day somebody asked her about it,
and she complimented the show and my performance.
And I was like, "Oh, I can die now.
Dolly Parton knows who I am and thinks I'm good."
-No, that's so cool. -So, yeah. But I'm still here.
-I didn't know she --
I didn't know she was, like, a silent producer.
-Yeah, little-known fact. Her partner was Sandy Gallin.
-Sandy Gallin. -Yeah.
-No way. -And they produced "Buffy."
-Isn't that wild? -Yep.
-Now, I want to talk about this new series, "Wolf Pack."
You -- You executive produce this one here.
Do you ever have any hesitation going back into another,
like, supernatural type of thing?
You're like, "I'm not doing 'Buffy.'
There's not vampires."
-Well, yeah, but there's so -- such difference.
I mean, vampires, wolves. Like, totally different.
-Yeah, yeah. Completely. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You know, I think there's always hesitation, right?
Because you don't -- it's hard to have something
that people are gonna compare it to.
But I also love watching and being part of those shows,
so I think it's different enough.
And, you know, a few years have passed since.
-Oh, yeah. -You know, 20.
We don't have to, like, put a number on it,
but if we're gonna get specific...
-You don't have to, yeah. -It's been some time.
-How do we describe "Wolf Pack"?
-Well, I describe it as basically --
It takes place in the L.A. fires,
which is something no one's, like, really dealt with.
But really at a deeper level, it's about anxiety.
It's about finding your pack, finding your people.
-It's two teenagers that kind of bond and then --
-Yeah, so two teenagers get bit when all of the animals
come out during the fire, and they find two other teenagers.
-Can we say what -- what happened?
We have to say it.
-What? They become werewolves? -Yeah.
-Well, I mean -- "Wolf Pack," right?
-Yeah, but you wanna say that.
They actually -- There's werewolves.
-See, this is why they don't like me
to go out and pitch these shows.
'Cause clearly I'm not good at it.
-No, this is all good. -We need to find somebody else.
-So there's two kids -- The two kids, they find --
They don't know each other. They get bit by the thing.
And there's werewolves? -And there's werewolves.
-That's all we want to talk about. I love this.
-There's werewolves. -I want "Wolf Pack."
That's what I'm talking about. I want to show everyone a clip.
-Starring Sarah. -Starring Sarah.
-Sarah. -Jimmy.
-Jimmy. Nice to meet you. -Nice to meet you.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Sarah Michelle Gellar in "Wolf Pack."
Take a look. -I'm so jealous.
-I need your help, Everett.
I need you to help me figure out
who's responsible for the deaths of several people.
That includes some of your friends
who were on that school bus.
♪♪
You're gonna hear that the police suspect arson.
That's only part of the truth.
Because it's not just a suspicion.
I know for certain this fire was caused by arson.
I can tell you I'm certain of one other thing.
The arsonist is a teenager.
Might even be someone you go to school with.
In fact, it's quite possible
this teenager was on that bus with you.
-Come on. That's how you do it.
[ Cheers and applause ] Sarah Michelle Gellar!
"Wolf Pack" airs Thursdays on Paramount Plus.
More "Tonight Show" after the break. Stick around, everybody.